croatia a nato member state will
withdraw its troops in the event of a
war with russia this comes as nato is
increasing its presence in ukraine
croatia's president zoran milanovic was
very blunt about what's going on there
so who is the leader of a small european
country of just over 4 million
inhabitants who's standing up to the us
and nato on this issue and why is he
doing it
zoran milanovic became croatia's
president back in 2020 when he beat the
then president kolinda grabar kitarovic
who used to serve as assistant secretary
general for public diplomacy at nato and
was always very cozy with the west
i love you babe
oh that's cute the new president
milanovic is a little less touchy-feely
and i think that's because he's very
aware of what can happen when two
similar nations get entangled in a
conflict when milanovich was croatia's
prime minister a few years back he was
very much against the removal of
cyrillic signs in the croatian town of
vukovar which has a very large serbian
minority that uses cyrillic hardcore
croatian nationalists were furious
[Applause]
milanovic was accused of being a
yugoslav but he stood his ground as he
remembers the war between croats and
serbs in 1990s yugoslavia that brought a
lot of death and suffering a war between
two nations that have such minute
differences as acknowledged by milanovic
and i think milanovich sees a similarity
between the relationship between croats
and serbs and ukrainians and russians
ukraine itself has seen right-wing
ethno-nationalist ideas prevail
emilianovich was a witness to this in
2014.
team
croatia's president was immediately
attacked by croatia's prime minister
and that may be because president
milanovic accused his prime minister of
charltonism from visiting ukraine while
milanovich's comment was immediately
attacked by ukraine's president zelansky
who tweeted if more than 100 000 troops
were on the border with croatia
president milanovich would call the
ukrainian prime minister's visit to
zagreb not charltonism but a
manifestation of solidarity and
friendship um both serbs and croats
unlike the us or the uk know very well
what it's like to have troops at the
border so maybe zelensky should do some
research before tweeting i'm not
endorsing milanovich or anything like
that i'm just saying he made some good
points and yes showed bravery in taking
a peace-oriented approach to u.s policy
in ukraine
we've heard a lot of experts talking
about what a war between russians and
ukrainians could mean but maybe we
should listen more to people who
actually went through a war between two
similar nations let's hope that these
voices of reason win the war between
policymakers